boole cat podcast special guest in here
my guy representing Hell's Kitchen New
York City yeah Marlin Craft Space Two
Out space two is up well actually this
is this is going to come out Friday
so yeah outrageous a lot of sad songs
right now lots of sad music a lot of sad
music for your head talk to it man
come on yeah
promise doing this
[Music]
destined to wake you up whiskey shot
need another like a booster girl love me
throw my [__] she a trooper staying
present only stop to think about the
future and how I'm a maneuver all the
[__] I had to go through I just use it
to grow through that's manure why they
worry about who's who but who's truer we
can't win everyone to win we need some
new losers cause they've been hating off
the [__] to kill us all and y'all
clapping all withdrawn wishing that that
[__] was you too but I'm a hater cause I
want the real to shine through you the
real in life is on the other side of
fear guess that's why I see my promise
now guess that's why these guys having
such a quiet year you either face Emma
become them speak up it's time to share
the Lion's Share profit goes in Pockets
that disgust me I'm kind of rare Prophet
they acknowledge and disgust me wonder
if I'm culpable for [__] as they entrust
me and fights to free the world my
fruits of Labor interrupting easy to
critique a venue sell out when you
busking get harder to see your own
reflection when you bubbling they tell
me what to do with the green but I made
it without a caddy and I damn sure ain't
putting I've been swinging long at the
end of the day I'm out here singing
songs where I go from there is to find
my baggage I bring along [__] I'm really
in it dog every word I write I really
live it though it Bears repeating like
if jog it back to back chips those ain't
your mans that's just a cast for you to
act with aptly name cause dudes all
broken from axing past tense so why
ain't trying to laugh at you or laugh
with it's magnetic me and challenges I
haven't met yet since the team every
loss I just add a lesson accumulating
wisdom like they tried the paper so when
I'm gone you can hear it in the vapor
hear the sex from a distance on the
bridge above the Riviera they see the
facts I'm making them for sound really
care much I know myself that's a
currency that's really scares bro so I'm
feeling Rich tell me who real is this
[__] I'm just true as I appear I ass
doubts making disappearances as Division
I lay doubts now clear as [__] belief's
a wild thing but you gotta try to be
great you can't just try to win with all
humility to those who not feeling me my
pros and my ability is nothing in the
face of the strength where my achilles
be I live off my weak spots my 20's been
one big detox I'm unlearning yeah I said
I'm unlearning yeah
Marla crap that was after this man my
man I appreciate you always bro I'm one
of them it's a Jedi right here
appreciate it Marlon craft bootleg cab
that was hard hey what up y'all
appreciate you guys watching this week's
freestyle we're dropping another one
next week and sometimes we drop more
than one in a week but they're always
brought to you by LRG baby that's right
loving me some LRG always and right now
if you go to the website
l-r-g.com and you use the promo code
bootleg you're gonna get 30 off 30 off
that's almost half
at checkout that's right all right shout
out to LRG one more time L Dash R Dash
g.com and when you check out use that
promo code bootleg and save 30 off the
freestyles we'll be back next week
always brought to you by LRG baby